thank you
foreign
hey
guys
foreign
[Music]
here we go
enough light
we out here is the lighting good
you look good
yeah yeah got the fresh cut
a lineup your boy got a lineup
your boy got a lineup O'Neal
line starts back here so I was like
oh
hilarious
what's goody hot Brothers
we're the best YouTube channel in the
world if you're looking to get good at
comedy no big deal
go fast you know
we're just out here slinging feedback
maybe just a little light work
just a little light work
there we go I'm trying to get centered
oh there it is let me talk about getting
centered in life son
use my use my Prana
[Music]
the life force
breath
oh look
okay whoa eating eating carrots
oh we got people in here Dylan youngs
so this damn I wish I wasn't at work
right now got me swearing in here
well we're glad you you snuck in here
with us there Dylan
be grateful it's better in the
alternative
being unemployed
or as
Yoshi and I call it being a full-time
comedian
that's what
Dave says what's goody
goody what's goody mood deep Burma
Tavis Aikman yo we deep in here
we're about to get some joke feedback
don't mind all the noise that has
happened
you say noise
oh you can't hear it great
I don't know I had the music up though
is there something oh
no just a lot of
upstairs pounding kids
oh no I don't think we'll be able to
hear that not you good nobody's
listening to you anyway
yeah sure
yeah I've got stared
I'm trying to re-situate I did
I filmed a new YouTube video today
about
building Netflix
and I've tested out a bunch of different
b-roll and I had to like move my camera
all around the room
okay for test playing with b-roll
I was so Fancy no in terms like b-roll
and fancy
yay
oh there we go
oh just me says hello Joel and Yoshi
what's goody
I was hello hello oh
um
uh Sebastian just dropped a special
today
is that what you did the video you did
the video before the drop the the video
just happened to happen yeah um
yeah he I didn't know he was dropping a
special
inside information you know what I'm
saying
around you buddy but I'm about to start
trying to Time stuff out that way
that's a happy coincidence
as they would say
yeah I agree so yeah I definitely want
to get more hip to
maybe trying to ride Trends more
trying to work smarter because hey
oh
Jerry says is it just me or is Live
Comedy coming back with a vengeance lots
of new clubs in Phoenix and other venues
hosting comedy nights
yeah
oh for sure yeah I mean I think comedy
seller I think they've been open for a
while comedy sellers just opened a new
spot Up in Vegas
um
and then I didn't know about the new
clubs in Phoenix that's awesome yeah
that's dope yeah Phoenix is popping
yeah comedy is just I got great comedies
on a come up at the moment
yeah and you know
your boy did a video about the comedy
boom 2.0 and if it's destined to repeat
history like the boom in the 80s and how
it crashed I don't know if anyone
has subscribed to the Joe Barr's YouTube
channel but we dropping
we drop a hit I ain't even fronting on
them I ain't even fronting
fire fighter I don't even want a stun on
them
but Harry Pike just said I just watched
your Bert Kreischer video
and really enjoyed it
we're working on
um getting more than comedians watching
it but they're still loving it
hey all I know how to do is great
content for comedians that's uh
the richest demographic in the world
so funny
oh keto care last have you ever looked
at what comes up when searching YouTube
for this show I type in hot breath oh my
oh I don't know
what happens
my breath spelled with an e or without
the e
it's a cool building right
make you spell to eat
oh hot breath
[Music]
what's goody what's goody everyone
we about to do some joke feedback
podcast comes up as like
number
five or six which is pretty solid what
when you search hot breath
yeah
without comedy just hot breath
that's not bad ah how interesting well I
guess maybe my algorithm when I search
it oh there's a band called hot breath
yeah
good for them
good for them they're doing great mm-hmm
um sorry about me I mean carrots
everyone I'm getting
my vitamins I'm trying to eat healthy
between
now and Christmas
and I had a biscuit about two hours ago
so it's going great
my wife and I got a sourdough starter
for my mom and we were like oh we're
gonna let's make some sourdough recipes
and then instead we just made biscuits
last night
no sourdough biscuits just just biscuits
we're like well we're baking
Brian J said baby carrots is a cheat day
hilarious
and he said we had
uh he'd like to see us swap hairstyles
oh if I had some of that luscious those
luscious locks of yours
you couldn't tell me nothing baby white
privilege
no
no I think they call it follicle
privilege that's the correct term
all Hair Matters
[Laughter]
pick up did you vote
I did vote let's go
yeah because they would stop texting you
good Lord
stop emailing
I'm over here trying to poop and Snoop
yeah
[Laughter]
and over here is just like all up in my
business hey hey hey
you vote yet
exactly it's smart we gotta do it
gotta do it now more than ever Jesus
there's not a lot of free things in this
world but voting is right yep
well well
um what's the joke feedback hour
um
chapter Sandy Bernstein for winning our
100 joke contest this month
let's go Sandy
yeah
I was gonna say Northwestern Mutual for
coming through with the bag this weekend
Amen Let amuse you
[Laughter]
amen
it was so I was talking to the bartender
before
the event and she's talking about how
she's sold out I was like are they
drinking a lot she's like well I'm
almost out of Diet Coke
it's very funny
it was very funny
that's hilarious I'm almost out of Diet
Coke
that's so funny
oh look at you look at your lights
little fancy pants we tried we tried
something
did you have a good weekend
uh yeah man just put the uh weekend in
Philly with the kids every year uh I
take my kids to a Philadelphia Eagles
game and so this was our weekend and it
was also my little one's birthday so we
kind of celebrated a little bit there
got him some candy took him out a little
bit so it was fun man it was a good time
it was a good bondy weekend didn't even
think about comedy which is always
um
I said it's always good not to think
about comedy or not to have it in the
back of your brain but this week is busy
because I've got
you know
Mercedes-Benz is coming through with the
bag this week so I'm excited wait a
minute oh that's right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
great so thank you for that referral Mr
buyers yeah that's gonna be fun
appreciate you for that one so
um and then I got a DJ Gig also on
Saturday a hosting and DJ Gig so that's
gonna be good on Saturday so you know
busy week
um overall but I'm really just been on
uh just writing a lot of jokes for this
Mercedes gigs because it's a roast
and it's like this is like my element
because I love
talking smack about Executives because I
just know them I've been in that before
and this is gonna be fun you're gonna
kill that dude you're gonna kill that
it's gonna be so fun
yeah
yeah it's gonna be good
and I'm gonna try to get up on stage too
no we're busy and we're still doing this
y'all so you're welcome and
and
feedback you know what I'm saying don't
worry about it so if y'all do have jokes
you want feedback on or if you have a
question
you'd like answered we're happy to do
that as well
we had a we had a hot breath tour as
well
um Bobby Sutton and Joyce Lyles went on
a tour
and um they like went up through DC and
Baltimore and got to meet some other hot
breathers up there like Joan and Sandy
it was very very fun I love seeing these
kids out there getting it you know
um
who'd I saw did I see is it triller that
lives here Ryan yeah
yeah I saw him this weekend too
um actually went to uh punchline to see
um Caroline Ray oh nice so funny yeah so
funny yeah just like
it's just like a different level when it
comes to like someone who's like that
experienced who's just does this like
yeah like it's like light work but she
just has so
much fun like that's the thing I
definitely like took away from
her style is that like regardless of the
jokes like it was just she was just
having a good time with the audience
and that like made it more of an
experience than just like joke joke joke
jokes like she was just having a good
time with the audience kept them engaged
so it was just fun to watch so that was
awesome yeah I've never seen her live
but I mean I know she's a triple OG in
this game
yeah she's
she's nice I was like okay I see you I
see you just like it's just fun to watch
a different style and see the way that
people put
their things together oh yeah dude yeah
I love that yeah I I go to punchline a
lot of the weekends and even just watch
you know because they don't book me so
I'll go and watch and
you know just study
because they don't book me and that's
fine but it's not a big deal
[Music]
no I'm good
it's all good
forever I'm gonna I'm gonna be like 30
years in like punchline didn't book me
I'm gonna be at the Fox Theater guys I
had to come here because punchline
wouldn't book me and their Diner side
car
no I I love the punchline they're great
but it's it's fun to have fun
so fun to have fun so a little history
about the punch so did did Farber used
to have that room before the punchline
had it
yes
oh okay I didn't know that part
it just like it just came together I was
like oh so this was like because I
remember I did a show at Farmers was it
like side yeah Jerry Carver side room
side room yeah and I remember seeing
two characters that I never thought I'd
ever see in comedy
Tommy in a box yep
someone else like I think her name was
Christina something
um
but they were both wild wild I know
you're talking about the Christina lady
too
yeah
oh this is this is comedy I was like
whoa
I was not ready for Tommy in a box may
be a um maybe a Jeff Justice product
there I'm not sure uh I don't know
I think he did take Jeff's class
but Tommy in a box for people who don't
know was a guy who goes on stage with a
box on his head and he like opens it to
do jokes
yeah very bizarre
[Laughter]
you know comedy is subjective though you
know
he is very very subjective and sometimes
it won't subject you to laugh and you
know that's perfectly fine
for whatever it is that's why we're here
to help you all punch up your jokes as
well
no
[Laughter]
yeah
um but yeah that's what I was wondering
I was just it was just curious and then
like it just all came rushing I was like
I did comedy here did you ever go to the
original punchline
yeah I watch shows at the original
punchline actually the last person I saw
was Aisha Tyler
at the original punch line
um
and at a good time I remember I I got
her book and like the opener
was super funny
I forget what his name was but he was a
Middle Eastern guy
um but he was very funny I thought he
was hilarious but I didn't know like
comedy he just said like just a good
time and then Aisha Tyler was just very
like structurally sound like it was just
set up punch and like she was just like
knocking it out but I mean I had a good
time it was really funny but in watching
it back again I'm like okay like there
was a different level in watching that
versus like when I watched someone else
who just has like
like a party atmosphere kind of like
Caroline Ray Caroline Ray was like it
was like a party watching her
um and then some comedians are very
structurally sound but yeah she was good
I mean it was good it was a good show
but I didn't watch like a ton of shows
there
yeah that's like that place was
legendary because it yeah that's one
like that was like one of the oldest
clubs
um
in the 80s I got um
I got this sign I don't know what to do
with it
but
I um
I I took this sign when they were
closing
[Laughter]
oh
dude that is so legit I think I think
I think Rodney I I think I remember
Rodney Perry was outside and he saw me
walking out with it he goes like he goes
oh Joe got himself a souvenir
but that place was legendary it was one
of the few clubs that's like was around
since the 80s and they had all the
signatures on the
yeah
you wonder why they don't book you
they hadn't booked me before then
I just want to make sure they didn't
that's hilarious
no that's legit they don't care about
that sign that's awesome though no it's
hilarious it's so funny dude that should
be in your background that's so funny
so funny it's such a good
it was like their last show it was like
Craig Robinson was like the last show
they did
at the punch line he like did the last
weekend there so I went like watched
that and then
yeah
absolutely that's awesome
oh Jerry Woodruff is watching in our um
Facebook group
very nice what goodies what's goody fam
oh
very nice
oh Jesse said that OCD joke that she
tried worked on stage
oh that's what's up nice
congrats see we're doing something Joel
[Music]
oh wait the other one all right
let's go
so
I guess we should get into some jokes
this is the joke feedback hour
it is that's what we've been told that's
why I'm here well we hear oh and Joan is
in here hey Joan what's good
crazed Haven Ryan Schwartz
crazy Davidson do you think it's
possible to just tell jokes on camera
put it on YouTube and make a living from
it
make some little story behind it to give
it a theme a closet comedian
um here's the thing I don't see why not
because
with the way that social media Tick-Tock
or as they call The Tick-Tock
certification if that's even a word is
happening there's a bunch of people who
are just making
clips that are going viral
and virality gets you booked to do other
stuff
and even if you don't want to get booked
virality still pays you
there's there's a comment
No Cap who posts Clips in his like room
he has like a backdrop and a light and
he's like acting like he's doing stand
up at a show and he has like some like
echo or like Reverb on the mic effect to
sound like he's in a room and he puts a
laugh track and he has hundreds of
thousands of followers
doing that
at first I didn't like it looks legit
and then I like then I all of his Clips
are like this thing and I was like and
then he had some at a live show and I
was like oh I see yeah yeah you can do
whatever you want the internet is the
Wild West
yeah do it see it see how it goes yeah
yeah
all right
Mike Marr what's goody fam what's goody
all right we got some jokes coming in
here maybe we should get to him so we're
not here until seven o'clock again
I gotta go eat biscuits
themselves
[Music]
I just yeah wouldn't it be nice to just
be able to
eat and drink whatever you want with no
repercussions
that's really what it is
yeah
what a bummer I mean what a blessing
foreign
what a blessing
all right
well all right
oh
I think I saw Harry Pike's joke
it got flagged by YouTube so let's see
I'll read it his are usually
I don't think we'll get canceled to read
in one of his
oh it just
okay let's see he says Christmas dinner
with vegans hold on
let's make sure we get this timer set
we want that timer there it is
all right so let's get get it
Christmas dinner with vegans
they want to show me how turkeys are
killed while I eat that's like holding a
newborn baby and the parents showing you
a video of how it was conceived
oh
um I like that are you gonna put it up
on screen I I can't because it was
flagged by YouTube so I was just reading
it off of YouTube
all right read it again so I can break
it down
break it break it break it good call you
you laughed
so that's yeah
that was a real laugh
I think it's a good analogy though oh my
gosh I have too many tabs open
oh for sure
my Ram is just
I'm the same way dude
that's what I got I literally bought
more Rams because of how many
because of your tab hilarious
um oh here it is okay Christmas dinner
with vegans they want to show me how
turkeys are killed while I eat that's
like holding a newborn baby
and the parents showing you a video of
how it was conceived
I mean
what a newborn baby I'll show you how I
was conceived
like it's a fun analogy I think I'm
trying to
I think the only piece that's like
missing is some kind of emotional
connection to the joke
whether you enjoy it don't enjoy it
like
there's just no connection to the joke
itself it just sounds like a like you're
just stating a fact it's gonna be the
only thing it's alarming
it's gross and something with analogies
is it's like whatever emotion you attach
to the first example that emotion must
be true for the next so it's like if you
say it's gross turkeys are killed like
them showing you turkeys being killed
then whatever the other end of that
analogy is must also be gross
like in order to bridge that Gap so just
remember that with analogies
but I like it really
I don't mind it it's not bad
yeah I think I like the analogy I think
just the wording could be like tightened
and maybe personalized
yes I think personalization is the key
there but uh but I like the analogy
overall there hairy hairy
Ari Ari irie Arie
you realize we do this every time we say
a joke every every point
Eric Pike
that we're so terrible
but guess what we're full-time comedians
we can't get canceled from a real child
[Music]
he said all right
yeah you like that all right all right
we gotta get on the show one day
haha laughs
I think about it every week I'm not even
every week I'm like okay I'm gonna Reach
Out
and this is we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it next Tuesday we're gonna get
them on and then next for sure this
next Tuesday is for sure the one
for sure
I feel like this is becoming Matt Damon
on Jimmy Kimmel hilarious it's Adam
Mueller
you can make the show this week next
week for sure
next week for sure
I do want to I'm a fan of Adam I wanna
have him on
very funny yeah
um next joke is oh my gosh
um
sorry this this match has gotten me
buzzing over here I'm got the got these
carrots and matcha I'm just over the
moon right now y'all I can't even
foreign
here we go
mudit
on the screen
[Applause]
uh
today's trend is using AI to make
self-portraits as in
as an IVF kid all my photos are already
of AI artificial Indian
ah
yeah I mean
funny
we're like we can't get canceled and
then we're like should we even comment
on this
am I allowed to say even Indian I don't
want to be problematic
I mean I think really the only way I
could make it better is like I mean it's
a solid joke I think really just as an
IVF kid
all my
photos are AI artificial Indian without
the already because you have no
reference to already what so like that's
really the only thing I would say but
that's pretty funny
I like it yeah and it could be like
being an IVF kid makes me Innovative all
of my photos
are AI artificial Indian
but he ended on the punch word which is
great
um yeah I don't hate it though I like it
yeah I mean and also like this is also
one of those where I think you almost
have to you also
um
should put an emotion into this
in some way like
almost like it's great that it's
trending right now or like you're
excited that it's trending of people
using AI self-portrait because then it
punches of why you're excited that you
are already Ai and artificial oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so just personalization to this
would make this pop I like it nice
yeah good job Indeed oh and John mon
dragon in here says
what's goody fans
what goody
yeah yeah
that way
um crazed Haven said it's hard to add
all that to these limited characters
um
we have learned that if you can't fit it
in the YouTube character limits then
it's probably too wordy
I mean if you say trash
[Laughter]
[Music]
y he ain't wrong
is
we're only working with one bit of a
joke obviously there's bigger bits to
the joke
but the goal of the feedback is to help
you with one small piece of the joke but
it's the part that should have a set up
and a punchline right you can add more
elements to it and yes we understand
that you know in a speaking setting you
might make it longer but the goal of
this feedback is to help you with like
the basis of the joke so then we can
help you figure out how to at least make
it pop make it stick out you know find
an element that may be missing or
Elevate the joke in itself so
yeah some of the jokes that we hear that
you and I have done we say it very
differently on stage
um
facts about when we do but when we do
the feedback or when we write it
probably just starts out super simple
but that's the goal
exactly yeah and crazy Haven said adding
the emotion and all that can be tough in
the character limit
yeah so yeah it's all a process
oh
um Robert Brown was goody it's goody
just popped in here
and speaking
of
funny
fresh off her last joke getting good
reviews on stage we have Jesse coming in
hey trust me
all right I almost joined a cult
but they kicked me out because they
couldn't brainwash me into achieving
goals
I like it
um
I'm trying to think
like there's an element of like uh
what's the word I'm looking for like a
a play on words or like a callback of
joining a cult
I feel like achieving goals isn't
like surprising enough I feel like
they're I feel like there could be a
bigger twist there
you know what I was thinking that
achieving goals was the part about
joining the cult you know I'm saying
it's almost like
it's almost like a
I almost joined a cult today
but they kicked me out because I
couldn't achieve the goals of almost
like achieve the goal of joining like I
couldn't follow through
you're saying something all right
that's where my head went with this
hmm
and even join right
I mean
maybe that's
couldn't brainwasher into
what else is with a cult was it Kool-Aid
some of them are
um polygamy
um
couldn't brainwash me into the van
I don't know it's just like something
unique to a cult like achieving goals
isn't unique trait of a cult
like what is something specific to a
cult
that
yeah you know what I mean and I think
that's the thing you almost have to put
the part about you being
you almost have to label the part about
you either being like a procrastinator
which I think she just mentioned or like
having like having a deficiency where
the cult couldn't like
wouldn't take you
now if you took the joke the other way
kind of like what you said about the
Kool-Aid or like the van I think there's
a element there that's super funny I
almost joined a cult today because but
they kicked me out because I couldn't
fit in the van or like they kicked me
out because I wouldn't drink the
Kool-Aid because I'm a diabetic or
something like that or I hate shoes
yeah or I hate sharing yeah yeah
there's something there but if you don't
put some element about yourself into it
then the achieving goals to your point
has no
there's no assumption there so there's
no assumption around achieving goals
that's what's missing from the formula
is that we're assuming a cult but
achieving goals there's no assumption to
achieving goals with a cult
yeah it almost seemed to be like a
specific type of cult Maybe
yeah like an an organized cult
so it could be try I almost got joined I
almost joined an organized cult but they
couldn't brainwash me into you know
being organized or dyslexic or add like
then something that's the inverse of
organized
I don't hate that
I don't like that either yeah that's
solid nice sure it seemed like it was
going to take over my life and I never
let anything take over my life not even
my own goals that's funny mm-hmm I like
that a lot
nice
somebody said I joined the cult but I
have ADHD and couldn't do the initiation
oh where do you see that one
I think oh from Facebook oh
yeah
that's funny oh that's right nice
okay awesome
that's a good edit Victoria mm-hmm
uh next joke we got Moody We got Jess me
Bob Kirk
a finalist of this month's contest
yay
this is yours
I was just taking a sip of dramatic sip
of Macho
got a busy night of decorating the tree
gotta gotta get woke here
hey for real for show for sure
um
Bob Kirk I have diabetes high blood
pressure and I'm just happy to still be
alive at my age every birthday is a
surprise birthday I'm still here give me
cake and a shot of Jameson's
all right
oh let me start the timer
I feel like
[Laughter]
oh you go no Hugo
go to the next joke
um
we just spent 15 seconds just laughing
at the approach right
um happy still be alive at my end of her
birthday surprise birthday
it could be
at my age
every birthday is a surprise if I
remember it
yeah the give me a cake and a shot of
Jameson
is more just an iteration of
you having diabetes and high blood
pressure
so like
I think I'm
it's more of a statement and I think
it'll like make a crowd Rowdy but I'm
not sure there's a punch line here
where I think the punchline is more that
every at every birthday is a surprise
birthday that's where the punch line is
yeah it's like surprise I'm alive that's
the punchline
yeah
yeah at my age every birthday is a
surprise
that I survive it
so maybe this is just one of those you
just rearranged the order
yes sir give me cake and a shot of
Jameson because every birthday is a
surprise birthday
cake
good
[Music]
husky Joels on the show
give me a cake
[Laughter]
hilarious nice it's ridiculous
give me a cake
um looks like Victoria's next
Victoria
have paid I have ptsds I have PTSD from
having a retail store I worked in get
held up with six guys with guns so when
I walked into a TJ Maxx just now the
security guard had one arm
I don't discriminate but what would the
guy do if there was a hold up how would
he help out I think every security guard
should be armed
oh boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh boy
oh it's a long way to get there
you had to take the Oregon Trail back
through
but see Victoria
she she joins on Facebook because
there's not a character limit on
Facebook now we've been through this
with Victoria before
she thinks she can
just Southpaw it like we're not gonna
notice half the screen is full of text
right now
[Laughter]
but yeah
one arm I don't discriminate but what
would the guy do if there were a hold up
how would he help out I like my security
guard to be armed like the joke is there
but we don't need
all of that so
yeah
I have PTSD from work in retail when I
saw six guys Rob the store
I just saw a security guard who had one
arm
every security guard should be armed
like that's the joke you don't say like
this is so much context and might work
if you're doing like a longer fit but
you don't need all this to get to the
punch line because here's the thing a
punchline is just the first funny thing
that you say There's an opportunity to
say more funny things
about this you know what I mean um
so just think about that from a joke
perspective and if you're doing a joke
especially about like this type of
scenario
once you get there you're gonna get like
a
grown people might like if it takes you
this long the same way me and Joel
reacted we're gonna be like uh okay
yeah you took us all in that way to get
to this
you get there faster then you can give
us more later like then you can like hit
us with more jokes around the one arm or
more like
relationships around being in the store
like there's other things you can do
but it took so long to get to the punch
line that we might lose interest so just
think about that
nice
all right all right all right all right
next up
next uh
keto Carol okay
[Music]
uh I love Disney movies because they set
real estate expectations for women they
taught me that handsome men are
unreliable and that all my needs would
actually be met by animals and very
short men
oh that's funny
I like that
[Laughter]
that's all there
for women
all my needs would actually be met by
animals
and very short men
uh
expectations for women
I mean
I don't know I wonder if she's done this
on stage I mean it sounds good to me
yeah like and my mind automatically went
to
um there's like all my needs would be
met by animals and short men and then I
immediately went to like a joke about a
rabbit as a sex toy a joke about any
other like other animal like things that
met your needs as well so that's where
my mind went
um with this but it's very very funny
it's a solid joke
[Music]
yeah and and you could get more specific
with
I know met by animals are very short men
I mean
I guess if you know Disney in general
you would get that I mean I guess I
don't know the specific movie
she's referencing but um
I mean I would probably just say you
could probably just say two of my
favorite Disney movies
are like Snow White
and uh
try to think of an animal movie
oh yeah but if it's um
Sleeping Beauty aren't there animals in
that so maybe it could be I love
the movie Sleeping Beauty because it set
really expectations for women and then
so maybe instead of Disney movies it's
sleeping Snow White
or Cinderella yeah I think instead of
Disney a specific Disney movie we'll
help out a little more specificity and
context to the punchline
that's a good point because Disney is so
large yeah
in such a wide universe you might get
lost in people trying to figure out
which Disney movie yeah the audience
will be trying to think okay well which
movie is that instead of telling them
and now they can just laugh
yeah good point that's a good one though
that's funny
Pamela says guys stop mansplaining
hilarious
um next joke
Robert Brown
I hate being the center of attention
especially around people I know that's
why you never catch me dead at a funeral
[Music]
super silly very funny though
that's really funny is that is that your
joke did Robert write that that feels
like something that could be
um like on Twitter or something
I think that's the thing about this joke
is that I don't know if people will
catch it
on a stitch from a stage perspective
yeah I mean yeah it's it's playing on
the the phrase you'll never catch me
dead anywhere or whatnot
yeah so
I don't know I mean
and it seems like a joke that may be
kind of more like ah I see what he did
there you know as opposed you know what
I mean like there's some jokes they're
just like ah I see
I had a great compliment one time
doing shows in Greensboro North Carolina
a guy and his wife came up after and
said
you're not haha funny
you're aha funny
[Laughter]
and he meant it as a compliment
ah
[Laughter]
yeah
you're not a [__] yeah right yeah
hilarious yeah what are you gonna do I
was like I've got merch
yeah they bought a koozie it was fine
[Laughter]
I've got aha Koozies yeah
it was great
so funny never forget that was also that
entire weekend I have the I have the
joke about where I humped the mic stand
doing the football act out
yeah that joke bombed
every show
and
if that joke bombs I'm I'm humping a mic
stand on stage in silence
and it bombed every show and every show
I was like this is the one
they're bombed every time foreign
the thing about that joke is like it
like builds so if the beginning isn't
getting a lap it's like oh no like
like and I just kept going I was like
I'm gonna get them by the end of it and
then I never did but like that joke if
the beginning isn't working it's gonna
be a rocky rest I've bailed in the
middle before because the beginning
wasn't working
but then I didn't I just went for it
that's so funny because I can just admit
so this thing I've seen you do that joke
like at least three or four times
and I can't imagine I mean and every
time I've seen you do it it does well so
I can't imagine it just dying
but you were so into it and all I see is
just you just riding that mic stand for
dear life yeah
I can't imagine you doing it to silence
because there's a lot of thrusting oh
yeah and it ain't gay it's football
laughs
yeah
oh yeah
that's hilarious
ah so it was a great weekend
um
next joke we have
um oh my God and we have a Harold
Harold's first time here
welcome let's go
what's goody Harold welcome aboard
um
this is just a silly one crazed Haven
said if Kanye got a master's degree in
literature could he become the world's
first grammar Nazi
[Music]
now that on Twitter and see how it goes
yeah
I see I see the joke there
um
that could also be yeah it's kind of
like the the other joke the dead at the
funeral that feels like one that could
be like on Twitter or Reddit or
something you know
um but the word plays there I see
um
Tavis
is this yours
I think so
or maybe yours actually this is yours
yeah who will count that we won't count
the yeah definitely not
[Laughter]
but we appreciate you know what crazed
Haven is giving Harold
tips on putting joke at the beginning of
his post and all that so we appreciate
the help there despite us roasting your
joke we appreciate you
um all right Tavis my psychiatrist said
we couldn't see each other anymore
because she was developing feelings for
me
feelings of hatred I looked at the bill
and said feelings Mutual
all right
hilarious
oh he gets me every time that's so funny
yeah
I've seen the bill from the couch
therapist and it's like damn my emotions
you know listen to hard crap is you know
it's expensive you gotta go in network
fam
gotta go ahead
because I didn't know caddy issues were
300 an hour
yeah you're giving me money issues
oh that's that's a great tag I thought I
had mommy issues now I've got money
issues oh that would be a good tag for
Tavis yeah go mommy issues the money
issues that's funny
but I do like it I think just for word
economy
she was developing feelings oh well
really I don't know if you need for me
she was developing feelings pause of
hatred
and then I looked at the bill and she
said and said feelings Mutual like
feelings for me pause feelings of hatred
like it there's not it needs to be
Titan there
yeah
that's funny
that's very funny nice nicely done alert
the mommy issues the money issues is a
funny tag too
that's good
that's so good
Jerry said live joke feedback is cheaper
just write your issue with the word
joking from it
hilarious
[Laughter]
that's great
hopefully our joke feedback doesn't
make you go to therapy yeah
hope not then we end up in someone's
therapy
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh next from Danny
here we go
my uncle from Guinea has a weird
Christmas tradition when idiots try to
steal from his farm he holds them up and
cuts their nuts off then he hangs the
balls from the pine tree traditional
oh
what just happened
what's that's graphic
but also I'm trying to figure out if I
miss something
from his farm he also
yeah that's it's just a phrase
yeah I don't
I mean it's dark
first of all yeah
yeah if he's just cutting off people's
nuts but I guess I'm just thinking about
like
Christmas tree
yeah like what am I missing
yeah I'm not sure something with from
Guinea so is this a I don't yeah but
regardless there's no
um there's no like joke structure it's
literally like a phrase you know what I
mean
so it's like instead of weird Christmas
tradition
um write a different joke
um nah
but the misdirect would need to be in
the setup to where it's like a
heartwarming Christmas tradition or an
intimate Christmas tradition like
something to build up a misdirect that
it's something actually violent and not
uh like homely
you know what I mean like right now it's
just kind of a phrase
ah
yep what y'all say
um
uh next next next next next next next
next next next
is it Harold
it is maybe Harold
um
I'm not saying any before very nice oh
my gosh Harold
held maybe the last one OMG
newbie here we go
all right tennis and comedy have a lot
in common difficult to get started hard
to get good at and no one cares really
the biggest difference is when I started
out with tennis
people laughed
all right
I like he's uh working with an analogy
those are fun
tennis and comedy have a lot in common
difficult to start
hard to get good at
and no one cares the difference when I
started I mean really the the big
misdirect here is with tennis people
laugh
um
and when I try really hard people laugh
difficult to start
hard to get good at
like and if you're gonna do like a power
of Threes here
uh the third one needs to be like a
complete surprise turn like it needs to
be as we call a third absurd if you will
but it really there needs to be like two
normal and then the third one needs to
be like a surprising misdirect right now
it's like they're all kind of
the same this would be to be like
difficult to get started hard to get
good at
and uh I end up in jail I mean that's
not the answer but like a surprising
turn on the third one
yeah I think the other piece is really
you don't need the part where it says
really the biggest difference is
I think you just say when I started
tennis people laughed
that's the comparison to Comedy mm-hmm
and maybe I don't I get laughs I don't
get laughs on purpose or like when I try
really hard people laugh
for the wrong reason
um
or my comedy is like my tennis game
but really the misdirect is around
when he plays tennis he gets a laugh
but at least when I play tennis people
laugh
to go to start hard to get good at
foreign
[Laughter]
has ideas for Harold but we hope that
helps just knowing the power of threes
um the third one needs to be like a
surprising twist something absurd
are unrelated to the first two
like crazed Haven said end up sweating
out of breath
yeah flop oh in court
say said or in court that's interesting
Tennyson comedy have a lot in common
it's difficult to start hard to get good
at and I always end up in court
like court and comedy
yeah that's a funny misdirect but it's
not necessarily connected to Comedy
um I follow the no one care up unless
you're successful
okay so he's following yeah so there's a
as I'm thinking about tennis there's a
phrase of when I swing something about
swinging and missing when I swing
like in comedy
no one laughs or something like that but
I think there's there's an analogy this
is where I would say crack out a nice
little Venn diagram and see what you can
find
yeah that's a good thing with analogies
is
a Venn diagram can really help you find
connections
so you want to like a Venn diagram is
you're comparing you have a column you
list everything you think of about
tennis everything you think of about
comedy and then the middle column like
the parallels between the two things
that are true for both of them
and then you can find connections that
way
but usually especially younger Comics
they kind of go with their first idea or
they go with the first three or four
ideas
but yeah what'll really help you
separate from the other comics
is you go eight nine ten examples deep
because like the first few things you
think of are going to be based on
your own bias your own experiences your
own like other people's impression on
you and once you get past all of that
you get into like the deeper more
subconscious examples that the audience
is going to resonate with
because comedy hinges on surprise so
when you create these surprising
connections that's when you really get
the big laugh so it requires a lot of
Excavating to get those so
a lot of a lot of young Comics well
comics in general we we have a funny
idea we're like oh that's good enough
but when you really dig deeper that's
when you find the goals
that's why they call it comedy gold
because you really gotta dig for it
the shoes just
[Laughter]
hilarious
oh Harold said just found about you
today a colleague told me
started out this October you'll see me
here
often for sure all right awesome
we love it Harold
we love it thanks fam well welcome to
the hot breath up first big facts oh
yeah and Mary said this is a good clip
for a short nice
yeah we did drop bars right there we did
drop bars
Joe bars
called Joel bars
all right
yeah we do this every Tuesday at um 5 PM
Harold and then every Wednesday at 10
A.M
I do a live joke riding exercise where
we get a new word and write a new joke
together so come on back
tomorrow morning if you won't
um but yeah let's land This Plane what
do you say
ing
well we appreciate y'all so much
yes Gracie anyone can try yes yes indeed
Joel cereal bars says keto Carol oh
don't get me started on cereal
don't get me started on cereal bruh
trigger work right there
girl's trying to trying to make me
backslide she's gonna make me relapse
like
yeah Gracie post your joke we're about
to leave but we'll sneak it in here
what you got
come here goodbye
bye Mary have fun
all right we're in it on Gracie's joke
here
Gracie is this Gracie's first time here
perhaps
but I mean goodness while um
while we're at it if y'all haven't
subscribed to my personal YouTube
channel go do that I just dropped a
banger about Burt Chrysler then
bruh
foreign
[Music]
I do love how excited you get about
what
your post I do I I'm super jazzed about
him for sure
um
okay
Gracie's joke
oh wait
do you think Jesus got annoyed when
repeat offenders asked him for
forgiveness
it's not like he was perfect
do you think
Jesus got annoyed
well
I don't know are you asking because like
a youth pastor is that why you're asking
this because this might be Gracie's
first time
I'm I'm just thinking
the one thing that stands out to me is
that there's no Gracie in this joke
it's like a
a general observation there's no Gracie
I always love to hear jokes that like
there's
the comedian's point of view on it or
the comedian's opinion about it or the
community it's a comedian's personal
experience this one
I mean I see it
do you think Jesus got annoyed when
repeat offenders asked him for
forgiveness
it's not like he was perfect
I just like it to hear a personal like
Gracie's opinion on this instead of just
like a general question anyone could ask
that she said come on I made the joke
great Gracie's Gracie's getting upset in
here do we need to pray
here
everybody hold hands everybody hold
hands across
hopefully Gracie doesn't know Jujitsu
like her name suggests
Jiu Jitsu but
uh but it's not the hard part is that
it's a it's a question
and you don't really have that
interaction with the audience to just
ask a question because then they're
going to be more inclined to answer you
but that's not you telling a joke as a
comedian so I would say to help with the
joke I would rephrase it for more of a
statement rather than a joke and yes
we're all going to pray for Graces
there's no personal perspective in this
it's more of a blanket statement this is
like one of those that you can find I
don't know if you can find this in a
Snapple box but maybe like a Jesus
Snapple box or something communion
a communion bottle
um
so yeah you got to add some personality
into it
I were Jesus
I would get annoyed when repeat
offenders ask me for forgiveness
like even that
resonates with me more
than
um just the general question
and if if like Jesus and religion is
something personal to you Gracie I would
say keep tapping into that topic but if
it's not and it's more of just kind of a
general like oh here's a joke idea
then like ask yourself questions about
what is unique about you and your life
and your experiences and your points of
view and your opinions like
those are great places to start writing
material from to really write that
personal material that's going to help
you to find your voice faster
so if religion if this is more just kind
of like a one-off thing then I'd say dig
deeper get into your own personal life
and your own personal experiences you'll
find a lot more material that way
yeah
facts nice oh and she said got it yay
I'm Glad We snuck that one in there I
hope that helped there Gracie
did it
[Music]
right
yay
all right let's land This Plane my
friends we appreciate y'all for hanging
out with us goodness gracious
you took a turn and then we came back to
the plane ride and we was like hey we
gotta land this thing we out yet the
Chisel
well thank you all so much for hanging
out we do it every Tuesday at 5 p.m so
do
tell your comedian friends we outcha
Hello friends hello friend subscribe to
our YouTube channel subscribe to
my personal YouTube channel
if you like Dope video essays
and supporting a kid's dreams
yeah support our games so if our wives
don't leave us amen amen amen amen
mm-hmm
[Music]
Amen Let Them use you
go on kids
y'all have a good day out there we love
you so much
We Ready Yoshi
you ready